[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marietta Slomka guten Abend
wenn man den Bogen überspannt fliegt der
Pfeil irgendwann ins lehere die
Erfahrung hat jetzt auch Ungarns
Regierungschef Wik Orban gemacht
der ganze EU Sondergipfel in Brüssel
fand ja im Grunde genommen nur statt
weil er sich bislang weigerte einem
neuen Hilfspaket für die Ukraine
zuzustimmen wie sehr er die anderen
Europäer damit nervte bekam er deutlich
zu spüren und muss auch gesehen haben
dass sie Mitstreiter fehlen zugleich gab
es hinter den Kulissen noch eine
spezielle französisch-italienische
charmoffensive Emmanuel macron und
Georgia Meloni sollen Orban in den
letzten Wochen und Tagen intensiv
bearbeiten haben um ihn aus dem Graben
in den er sich eingebuddelt hatte
herauszuholen und so endete der Gipfel
heute mit einem Erfolg Isabel schfas
berichtet aus
Brüssel mindestens 1300 Traktoren
blockierten heute das Brüsseler
Europaviertel lautstark und teilweise
aggressiv versuchten Landwirte vor allem
aus Frankreich Deutschland Belgien und
den Niederlanden so ihre Anliegen auf
die Agenda des eugipfels zu
bringen wir Landwirte wollen dass die
Politik uns wenigstens erstmal
zuhört sie sollen merken dass sie die
europäischen Gelder besser verteilen
müssen zunächst an die eigenen Leute
dann erst sollten Sie sich um andere
kümmern einer der sich ebenfalls mit
Blockaden von EU-Gipfeln auskennt ist
Victor Orban er nutzte die
bauernproteste um mal wieder verbal
gegen seine Amtskollegen und die ganze
EU zu
schießen es ist ein europä Fehler dass
die Stimme des Volkes nicht ernst
genommen wird die Regierenden nehmen sie
einfach nicht
ernst doch heute Wiesen eben diese
Regierenden ihren Kollegen aus Ungarn in
seine Schranken unerwartet schnell
konnte er in kleiner Runde davon
überzeugt werden die Finanzhilfe für die
Ukraine doch freizugeben das ist jetzt
etwas wo wir als Familie als Europäische
Gemeinschaft zusammenstehen müssen und
das eben auch durch eine gemeinsame
Beschlussfassung zum Ausdruck bringen
gute Botschaft für die Europäische Union
gute Botschaft für die Ukraine schon im
Dezember wollte die EU der Ukraine die
Mittel freigeben 50 Milliarden Euro für
vier Jahre damals scheiterte das am Veto
Ungarns bis zuletzt hatte Orban
gefordert jedes Jahr neu über die Gelder
abzustimmen mit vetooption was er nun
bekommt ist fast nichts eine mögliche
Überprüfung der Finanzhilfen in zwei
Jahren natürlich können wir unsere
Entscheidungen überprüfen aber die
Ukraine braucht jetzt eine langfristige
Zusage das sieht auch der ukrainische
Präsident volodimir selenski so und
bedankte sich per videoansprache für das
einstimmige Votum der
EU-Spitzen heute hat die EU bewiesen
dass ihr Wort zählt und dass ihre
Versprechen den Interessen ganz Europas
dienen für die EU stand heute mehr auf
dem Spiel als die Entscheidung über die
ukrainehilfe einmal zu oft hatte Orban
alle aufgehalten und so die
Handlungsfähigkeit der EU immer wieder
in Frage gestellt
die Haltung Orbans ist eine Gefahr für
unsere Sicherheit das ist offensichtlich
und das ist inakzeptabel wir müssen
künftig in solchen Fällen alle möglichen
Konsequenzen in Betracht
ziehen die Bauern verlassen Brüssel
heute abend zumindest mit der Zusage
dass die euagrarminister sich mit ihren
Anliegen beschäftigen werden Viktor
Orban hingegen geht ohne Erfolg nach
Hause t fräin Brüssel das das wirkt ein
bisschen so als sei das heute so eine
Alles oder Nichts Veranstaltung gewesen
also entweder hätte die EU am Ende als
handlungsunfähig daagestanden oder es
wäre wirklich zum Bruch mit Ungarn
gekommen oder ja absolut ich glaube das
ist heute ein besonderer Tag Orban hat
ja seit langer Zeit der EU auf der Nase
rumganzt hat die EU erpresst und nun hat
die EU eins ganz klar gemacht sie hat
den in die Schranken gewesen und das ist
ein Erfolg und wie hat sie das gemacht
mit maximalen Druck sie hat ihm deutlich
gemacht wenn er sich weiter weigert hat
das einen hohen Preis seit Tagen ist in
Brüssel darüber diskutiert worden dass
man vielleicht EU-Gelder für Ungarn
einfach nicht weiter auszahlt und das
wäre eine Katastrophe gewesen weil die
ungarische Wirtschaft wirklich an den
Töpfen von Brüssel hängt und es ist
sogar über darüber gesprochen wden das
Stimmrecht vielleicht Ungarn zu
entziehen das ist ein kompliziertes
Verfahren aber man war so sauer dass man
auch darüber nachdenken wollte und das
sind schon se massive Sanktion die
wahrscheinlich Orban zum Nachdenken
gebracht haben und eben zum Einlenken
wie gesagt das ist heute ein guter Tag
für die demokratische EU und ein
schlechter Tag für den autoritär
denkenden Orban n hat man sich auf
Finanzhilfen an die Ukraine geeinigt das
ist das eine aber bei den Militärhilfen
also wenn es um Rüstungsgüter und
ähnliches Gil gibt
geht dann da gibt's ja nun durchaus
Spannung in der EU also auch den Vorwurf
dass sich da einige wegducken die
eigentlich sehr für mehr leisten könnten
ja ich glaube es war heute sehr wichtig
dass man diese Finanzhilfen für die
Ukraine beschlossen hat Amerika fällt ja
zurzeit ausgrund von innenpolitischen
streitereinen als Unterstützer für die
Ukraine aus und wenn man diese
Finanzhilfen nicht beschlossen hätte
dann wäre es sehr sehr schwer geworden
für die Ukraine sie braucht dringend das
Geld um Rechnung zu zahlen um
Krankenhäuser zu betreiben um die Renten
zu bezahlen insofern das ist ein Erfolg
was kein Erfolg ist das eben bei dem
Thema Waffenlieferung Munition ein
echter engpasdrot der Bundeskanzler hat
das sehr sehr deutlich angesprochen er
ist sauer er ist eigentlich der Ansicht
dass vor allem Italien und Frankreich
nicht genug tut und er hat heute sehr
klar gesagt wenn wir nicht die
Lieferungen erhöhen wenn wir nicht mehr
Waffen und Munition liefern dann wird
das für die Ukraine ein riesenprblem
also bei diesem Thema droht weiter
Streit danke schön Ulf nach
Brüssel ja 50 Milliarden das klingt
natürlich auch erstmal nach viel Geld
aber um einen großen Staat am Laufen zu
halten braucht es sehr viel mehr auch
deshalb setzt Russland ja darauf
möglichst viel zivile Infrastruktur zu
zerstören um die ukrainische Wirtschaft
in die Knie zu zwingen und der
Bevölkerung die Lebensgrundlage zu
nehmen wie kritisch die Zustände der
teils schon sind hat unsere reporterin
Anne brühlin nikolajev erlebt die
Hafenstadt im Süden des Landes an der
Schwarzmeerküste ist seit Kriegsbeginn
immer wieder Ziel massiv Russ
Angriffe es gibt Wasser aus dem han im
kriegsgeplagten mikolajev ist schon das
keine
Selbstverständlichkeit trinken kann man
es allerdings nicht denn seit
Kriegsbeginn kommt nur noch
Salzwasser wir waschen ab wir spülen das
Geschirr die Toilette noch alles andere
nehmen wir von dort trinken können wir
nur sauberes
Wasser von 80 Stationen die in der Stadt
inzwischen entstanden sind mit
finanzieller Hilfe aus Dänemark hier
können sich die Anwohner ihr Trinkwasser
abfüllen
jederzeit sobald diese fünf Flaschen
leer sind komme ich wieder hierher alle
vier oder 5
Tage früher habe ich sechs Flaschen
geschleppt das kann ich nicht mehr meine
Hände tun mir sehr weh meine Tochter ist
behindert und deshalb ma ich das ich bin
Wasser aufbereiten direkt vor der
Haustür Filtermembranen Tanks es ist
eine ausgeklügelte Technik die dahinter
steckt und die pro Station bis zu 10 000
Liter Trinkwasser pro Tag
produziert wir sehen das sehr positiv
natürlich brauchen wir Hilfe wie Sie
sehen können alles ist schwierig wir
haben Krieg in unserem Land offen gesagt
wenn wir nicht die Hilfe ausländischer
Partner hätten wäre es sehr schwierig
für uns
eine halbe Million Menschen haben vor
dem Krieg in mikolajev gelebt jetzt sind
es noch 350 000 früher haben sie ihr
Wasser aus dem Süden bekommen der ist
jetzt von den Russen besetzt seitdem
müssen sie auf Salzwasser aus einem
Meeresarm in der Nähe der Stadt
zurückgreifen eine perfide Kriegstaktik
sieht darin der Leiter der
Kommunalbetriebe wissen sie der Feind
hat eine neue Waffe eingesetzt er hat
beschlossen eine halbe Million Mens ohne
Wasser leben zu lassen und glaubte dass
die Stadt danach einfach aussterben
würde
überall in der Stadt ist das Trinkwasser
das zentrale Thema und überall gibt es
Tankwagen mobile Wassertanks von
unterschiedlichsten
Hilfsorganisationen ganz Europa hilft
uns wir sind allen sehr dankbar die
unserem Unglück nicht gleichgültig
gegenehen kommol das Trinkwasser wieder
aus dem
wasserhn nach Deutschland wer mobil sein
muss hat es hier zu Lande zur Zeit ja
nicht ganz leicht Stau wegen
bauernprotesten Streik bei der Bahn und
zwischendurch viel auch noch viel Schnee
heute Abend begann der Streik im
öffentlichen Nahverkehr unter an
Flughäfen war das Sicherheitspersonal im
Ausstand und 1100 Flüge wurden
annulliert betroffen waren davon mehr
als 200.000 Passagiere warum wird
derzeit so viel gestreikt der Frage ist
Dominik Müller Russell
nachgegangen es ist eine Demonstration
der Stärke heute vor dem Düsseldorfer
Flughafen mehrere hundert
sicherheitsbedienstete haben die
Arbeiten niedergelegt um mit breiter
Brust für bessere Bedingungen und mehr
Geld zu
trommeln man weiß selber wenn man
einkaufen geht heute hat man die Hälfte
für die gleiche Summe wie vorher
und das ist das Wichtigste gerade ja
weil wir mirhr Geld haben müssen da ist
ja alles teurer geworden und die
Arbeitgeber die kommen uns die entgegen
wir würden das ohne Streik machen das
ist kein was S angeboten haben das ist
kein Angebot das ist ein Witz einerseits
Sorgen wegen Inflation gestiegener
Preise und andererseits wissen sie um
ihre Macht denn es fehlen mehrere
tausend Beschäftigte in den
Sicherheitsbereichen deutscher Flughäfen
aus solch einer Verhandlungsposition
heraus lässt sich ein Arbeitskampf gut
führen
die Beschäftigten arbeiten so viel wie
noch nie es fehlen ja in allen
Branchen Fachkräfte das heißt wir haben
auch hier Menschen mit Überstunden ohne
Ende das zweite ist dass aber die
Angebote der Arbeitgeber immer noch zu
Reallohnverlust führen würden und beides
zusammen gibt eine Stimmung wo viele
Arbeitnehmer sich klar werden also was
kann ich denn tun um meine Situation zu
verbessern die Gewerkschaften erhalten
so viel Zulauf wie seit jah nicht mehr
wegen der Zukunftssorgen vieler
Beschäftigter aber auch durch die
Streiks an sich die für die
Gewerkschaften durchaus gute Werbung
sind doch nichts stärkt sie so sehr wie
die Situation auf dem Arbeitsmarkt wir
haben eine völlige Verschiebung der
Kräfteverhältnisse jetzt zugunsten der
Arbeitnehmer durch den zunehmenden nicht
nur Fachkräfte sondern sogar
arbeitskräftteemangel in vielen Branchen
kommen die Arbeitnehmer in deutlich
bessere
Verhandlungspositionen das haben die
Gewerkschaften natürlich erkannt und
üben jetzt einen stärkeren Druck auf die
Arbeitgeberseite aus doch die Wirtschaft
schrumpft sinkende Nachfrage und nicht
zuletzt die Auswirkungen der vielen
Streiks haben dazu geführt dass
Deutschland in eine Rezession gerutscht
ist hat das ifo Institut errechnet so
gesehen keine guten Zeiten für
mir die Inflation ist hoch deshalb
verstehe ich dass es hohe
Lohnforderungen gibt wir müssen aber
sehen dass wir als Volkswirtschaft
insgesamt auch ärmer geworden sind durch
die Inflation denn die kommt teilweise
von außen durch höhere Energiepreise und
wenn wir als Volkswirtschaft ärmer
geworden sind dann gibt's weniger zu
verteilen und damit auch nicht so hohe
Spielräume für lohnerhörung die Stimmung
bei den Beschäftigten ist allerdings
eine
andere heute nicht gefallen neues
Selbstbewusstsein heute Flugzeuge morgen
bleiben Busse und Straßenbahnen in den
depus weil ihr starker Arm es
will zu den Streiks halten wir Sie
natürlich auch online auf dem Laufenden
auf ZDF heute und jetzt geht's erstmal
bei dir weiter he vor der morgigen
Abstimmung über den Bundeshaushalt gibt
es einigen Wirbel um das
haushaltsfinanzierungsgesetz das Teile
dieses Haushalts betrifft anders als von
der Koalition geplant hat der Bundesrat
das Gesetz nicht auf seine Tagesordnung
für morgen gesetzt und bremst damit
unter anderem einen Beschluss über die
umstrittene Streichung von
dieselvergünstigung für Landwirte die
nächste reguläre Sitzung des Bundesrats
ist für den 22 März
geplant in der heutigen Haushaltsdebatte
im Bundestag hat Wirtschaftsminister
habck ein milliardenschweres
Sondervermögen zur Entlastung von Firmen
ins Gespräch gebracht ins Spiel gebracht
habck sagte er wolle in einen Dialog
darüber kommen wie die große
Transformation der Wirtschaft finanziert
werden könne er nannte etwa
Steuervergünstigungen und
Abschreibungsmöglichkeiten
und der Bundestag hat einem
Gesetzentwurf der Koalition zur Änderung
der Wahlkreise zugestimmt demnach hat
wegen der Bevölkerungsentwicklung
Sachsen Anhalt künftig einen Wahlkreis
weniger und Bayern einen mehr die CDU
warf der Koalition Willkür und
Manipulation vor die Regierungsparteien
wehrten sich gegen den Vorwurf und
verwiesen auf die rechtlichen Vorgaben
für den Zuschnitt von
Wahlkreisen mehr als 1,6 Millionen
Menschen in Deutschland dem AFD
Politiker Björn höcke einen Teil seiner
Grundrechte zu entziehen der Initiator
einer entsprechenden Online Petition
übergab eine Liste mit bisher
gesammelten Unterschriften an
Abgeordnete des Bundestags durch den
grundrechtsentzug der auf Antrag nur
durch das Bundesverfassungsgericht
erfolgen kann soll höcke unter anderem
das Recht verlieren sich wählen zu
lassen höcke ist Partei und
Fraktionschef der vom Verfassungsschutz
als rechtsextrem eingestuften Thüringer
AFD die Ukraine will eigenen Angaben
zufolge ein russisches Kriegsschiff im
Schwarzen Meer versenkt haben der
ukrainische Militärgeheimdienst
veröffentlichte ein Video das zeigen
soll wie mehrere drohen ein mit Raketen
bewaffnetes Schiff angreifen es habe
Schlagseite bekommen und sei gesunken
unabhängig überprüfen lassen sich die
Angaben nicht Moskau hat sich bisher
nicht dazu
geäußert Lieferketten Sorgfaltspflicht
Gesetz ist so eines dieser
Wortungetüme die nicht deutschsprachige
wahlweise erheitern oder zur
Verzweiflung bringen nach Ansicht vieler
deutscher Unternehmen ist aber nicht nur
das Wort ein Ungetüm sondern auch die
Vorschriften die damit einhergehen Tenor
Menschenrechte und Umweltstandards
einhalten ist ja richtig aber muss das
so kompliziert sein darüber ist jetzt
ein Streit entbrannt der wieder einmal
die Ampelkoalition aufreibt und zugleich
für Ärger in der EU sorgt denn das
deutsche
lieferkettenorgfalltspflichtengesetz
soll zu einem europaweiten Gesetz werden
im Wesentlichen war das in Brüssel schon
eingetütet doch nun will die FDP nicht
mehr mitmachen Guner Krüger erklärt
worum es da
geht anfangen muss man im Nordosten von
Indien um den Streit zu verstehen der
gerade von Berlin nach Brüssel schwappt
in Indien suchen Kinder unter
Lebensgefahren Glimmer ein Gestein
dessen Name sich erklärt wenn man weiß
dass es in Handys steckt in Autolack und
in Kosmetik um solche Produkte geht es
im europäischen Lieferketten
sorgfalltspflichtengesetz dass die FDP
nun vorerst stoppt ich bin für die
Stärkung von Menschenrechten und
ökologischen Standards aber ich bin
dagegen dass wir unsere Unternehmen mit
bürokratischen Lasten
so an ihrer wirtschaftlichen Aktivität
hindern dass sie kaum mehr für ständige
Menschen vernünftig durchführbar ist im
Entwurf gilt das Gesetz je nach Risiko
für Betriebe ab 250 Mitarbeitern die
sorgfalltspflicht reicht von Rohstoffen
über alle Zwischenhändler bis zur
Produktion die Haftung wird ausgeweitet
es sei damit strenger als das bestehende
deutsche Gesetz sagt so wie die FDP ein
Teil der Wirtschaft in Hamm Westfalen
haben Sie alles was Kantinen brauchen
20.000 Produkte alle sollen künftig
Umwelt und Arbeitsstandards erfüllen und
die Chefin muss das
nachweisen wir wollen natürlich
Umweltschutz und Menschenrechte
einhalten das ist wichtig aber wir
brauchen hier Lösungen die machbar die
praktikabel und die auch bezahlbar sind
das Problem EU-Parlament und
Mitgliedstaaten haben sich längst
geeinigt auch die Bundesregierung
stimmte im Dezember zu wenn sie sich nun
im Streit enthält dann verspiele sie
vertrauen kritisieren grüne und NGOs
Deutschland hat sehr lange bis
kurzvchluss mitverhandelt hat einige
rote Linien aufgestellt die wurden alle
nicht gerissen auch um die FDP an Bord
zu halten und dass man jetzt so kurz vor
Schluss die Reißleine zieht ist
europapolitisch unverantwortlich und da
jetzt zurückzutreten ist wirklich nicht
nur ein Schlag ins Gesicht für die
Betroffenen aber eben auch alle
Unternehmen die sich in den letzten
Jahren darauf vorbereitet haben darum
will der federführende Minister hallo
noch nicht
aufgeben ich werbe eindrücklich für eine
Zustimmung zu diesem zu dieser
Richtlinie und ich habe dazu einen
Vorschlag unterbreitet den wir jetzt in
der Regierung diskutieren um Brücken zu
bauen sein Argument wenn für alle
gleiche Standards gelten dann führe das
zugleich zu fairem Wettbewerb in Europa
und zu besseren Arbeitsbedingungen in
Indien ja mit dem Thema geht bei dir
jetzt auch noch mal weiter Schau wir
genau genauer auf die Positionen in der
deutschen Wirtschaft zum
lieferkettengesetz hört man da eine eher
einheitliche Haltung Frank betetmann
oder gibt es da unterschiedliche
Sichtweisen na es gibt die zwei Extreme
einerseits die weltweit mindest aber
europaweit aufgestellten Konzerne wie
Aldi hapglid aber auch Ikea oder der
Konsumgüterhersteller Unilever die das
lieferkettengesetz Begrüßen ein
EU-Gesetz würde einheitliche Regeln für
alle schaffen argumentieren sie die
mekosten die mit der Umsetzung verbunden
sind können sich die großen leisten
schwieriger wird es für kleine und
mittelständische Betriebe insbesondere
wenn sie in kritischen Branchen wie der
Textilindustrie der Agrar oder
Bauwirtschaft tätig sind hier die hohen
Standards zu erfüllen sei sehr schwer
und unverhältnismäßig teuer heißt es und
wie gehen die Unternehmen die da eine
starke Belastung sehen damit um ja es
sind stellvertretend die meisten
spitzenverbände der deutschen Wirtschaft
die schon seit geraumer Zeit gegen die
die EU-Richtlinie wettern sie ablehnen
sie sei wirklichkeitsfremd und würde den
Unternehmen uneinlösbare Pflichten
aufbürden beispielhaft wird immer wieder
der Bausektor genannt der könne die
gesteigerten Prüfpflichten gar nicht
leisten also wo kommen die Materialien
her wer hat sie wie gefertigt unter
welchen Bedingungen im Ergebnis würde
noch weniger gebaut in Deutschland
Grundtenor des ganzen man sei für
Menschenrechte gegen Kinderarbeit aber
die Regulierung dürfen die Betriebe eben
auch nicht strangulieren Frank betmann
vielen
Dank die Deutsche Bank setzt ihren
Sparkurs fort und will deutlich mehr
Stellen abbauen als bislang geplant
weltweit sollen etwa
3500 Jobs bis Ende nächsten Jahres
wegfallen wie Konzernchef sewing bei der
Jahresbilanz Pressekonferenz in
Frankfurt mitteilte mit dem vergangenen
Geschäftsjahr zeigte sich Deutschlands
größtes Geldhaus zufrieden trotz
Gewinnrückgangs für den unter anderem
die gestiegene Steuerquote
verantwortlich
ist in der Formel 1 steht ein
spektakulärer Wechsel bevor der
brietische Rekordweltmeister lewiis
Hamilton und das mercedesteam werden
sich zum Ende der Saison 2024 trennen
und zur Saison 2025 wechselt Hamilton
dann zu Ferrari das gaben beide
rennstelle am Abend
bekannt in der spanischen Region
Katalonien ist wegen Wasserknappheit der
Notstand ausgerufen worden ab morgen
müssen Industrie Landwirtschaft und
Viehwirtschaft den Wasserverbrauch
drastisch senken zum Teilung bis zu
80% auch für die mehr als 6 Millionen
Menschen in Barcelona und den rund 200
umliegenden Gemeinden wird der tägliche
Wasserverbrauch beschränkt katalonien
ist von einer anhaltenden Dürre
betroffen seit über dre Jahren gehen die
Pegelstände in den Wasserreservoirs
zurück viele stausehen sind fast
leer Hamburg steht morgen ein gehörig
Kulturspektakel bevor eine Weltpremiere
werdi AIDA als multimediales megaow
Ereignis es wird sogar litterweise
Parfum versprüht damit man das alte
Ägypten nicht nur hören und sehen
sondern auch Rechen kann das Publikum
ist sozusagen mit allen Sinnen dabei
nach der Premiere in Hamburg geht das
AIDA Spektakel dann auf Deutschland und
Europatour Petra Meyer konnte schon mal
bei den Proben
zusehen
der Triumphmarsch den kennt jeder ein
vor trompetenfanfaren nur so strotzendes
Stück es erklingt zum Ruhm des Pharaos
als seine siegreiche Armee
einzukält Oper im maxiformat WD zeitlose
Musik präsentiert mit den technischen
Möglichkeiten von heute für alle Musik
nicht geschrieben für eine Elite sondern
er hat die Musik geschrieben für den
normalen Menschen derjenige auf der
Straße musste musste mitbkommen was er
da was er da gemeint
hat
opan singende eindringlich nah sie
werden groß auf einer ledwand übertragen
jede Geste ist erkennbar ungewohnt aber
sehr echt findet das am nesdarstellerin
Sophia
maeno in dem Moment wo ich selber singe
bin ich so in der Figur hoffentlich dass
mir das eigentlich ziemlich schnuppe ist
ob ich groß oder klein auf der Leinwand
bin weil ich möchte einfach authentisch
in der Figur sein und wenn da vielleicht
irgendwie Spucke fliegt weil das nun mal
so intensiv ist oder Schweiß mir
runterläuft dann ist das ebenso ihr Ritt
auf der mit 4 m enormhohen Elefantendame
anyana ein besonderes Ereignis das
täuschend echtwikende Kunstprodukt ist
aufwendig dekoriert und wird von acht
Menschen
unsichtbar fortbewegt auf der Bühne und
in der Bark Arena sind bis zu 150
darstellende gleichzeitig die noch
leeren Ränge fassen 8000 Zuschauer diese
Größe und Opulenz so hätte es werdi wohl
gefallen heißt es ich bin froh dass wir
mit Mikrofon singen sonst würden wir
diese große Arena vielleicht nicht mit
unseren Stimmen
füllen Gruppenszenen wie diese werden
aufwendig und kleinteilig geprobt mit
lichton und Anweisungen von Rian van
Holland D Jahre lang hat sie diese AIDA
Produktion vorbereitet die jetzt kurz
vor der Aufführung steht es soll einen
einen mariage
werde zwischen Sänger und Tänzer
Schauspieler und damit und es so machen
dass das Publikum ja eigentlich nicht
mehr wisst wer singt dann und wer Tanz
bewegt
es ist intensiv und aufwühlend die Oper
als
Event ja das war im heute journal weiter
geht's gleich bei maybr ilner bei der
heute unter anderem Klaus Kleber zu Gast
ist bei einer Debatte darüber wie whrlos
Europa ohne die USA wäre um 0:30 Uhr
meldet sich dann Christopher wehmann mit
unserem heute schournal Update
Wiedersehen
[Musik]
Wiedersehen schönen guten Abend und
herzlich willkommen zum Wetter eine
Kaltfront beschäftigt uns noch in der
Nacht die zieht aber allmählich ab
bringt aber hier an den Alpen noch etwas
Regen und Schnee und die nächste Front
die erwartet uns von Westen her kommt
die auf und bringt Regen im Tagesverlauf
und zieht dabei ostwärts ab in der Nacht
gibt es schon die Wolken dazu mit Regen
im Nordwesten dazwischen lockert es auf
und ganz im Süden da ist eben noch
dieser Regen und Schnee in den höheren
Lagen von der Kaltfront dabei bei
tiefsten Temperaturen vom Saarland bis
Richtung bayischer Wald und Erzgebirge
im Frostbereich mit -2° ist es hier im
Osten am kältesten gr plus am mildesten
noch Richtung Nordsee morgen am
Vormittag regnet dann vor allem noch
Norden kräftig im Südosten ist in den
höheren Lagen Schnee dabei von Westen
her lockert es auf hier zeigt sich schon
mal die Sonne zum Nachmittag umso mehr
da ist dann viel Sonnenschein dabei der
Regen zieht ansonsten ab nach Osten und
dann wird's allgemein Trockner
Temperaturen erreichen 3° Richtung
östliche Mittelgebirge 10° am niederrein
und 11° Richtung oberrein sehr mild die
nächsten Tage am Samstag vor allem in
der Mitte und im Osten Regen der
allmählich ostwärts zieht im Süden auch
Sonnenschein 5 bis 11° Sonntag weiterer
Regen in der Mitte bei Werten von 7 bis
14° und auch Montag gibt's vor allem
nach Osten hin wieder Regen dann wird's
sogar noch milder bis 16° sind drin
damit einen schönen Abend